anthony is in trenton new jersey hi
anthony how are you
i'm good how are you dave better than i
deserve how can we help
all right so i'm a 23 year old
i live in new jersey i have a
2011 chevy cruze it's worth about two or
three thousand dollars
i also have a 2003 nissan 350z
and i drive the chevy cruze the 350z
which is kind of like a
i got it for cheap i just fixed it up
and uh i'm trying to sell it right now
um i have an apartment the rent is
about 1200 a month but i uh split it
with my girlfriend and
i pay 900 she pays the rest
i guess my question is i'm looking to
buy a new car
but what i have is kind of giving me
problems and stuff
so i'm looking to see maybe getting like
a toyota tacoma or something like that
um but the only issue is the car is
about fifteen thousand dollars and i
have eighteen thousand saved right now
and i'm just trying to see what you
think if you think i should
pull the trigger on something that
expensive or i should what do you make
uh fifty five thousand uh gross pay okay
well a rule of thumb i use is not on
things that have motors and or wheels
added together that equal more than half
your annual income because they all go
down in value
it doesn't sound like you're going to
violate that i'm a little confused as to
why you have two cars
um well the so sometimes like i buy cars
that are like
i used to work on cars so i know what's
there too about them um
the nissan was just a really good deal
and uh
so i just picked it up fixed some issues
with it and i was planning on selling it
oh
it just hasn't sold yet okay it's just
sitting in my driveway okay and so
you'd sell the you'd sell the chevy
cruze and your daily driver would be the
the tacoma well hold on a minute anthony
if you said you work on cars why can't
you fix the one you drive
i can but the thing is the work that it
needs it
costs about you know it'd probably be
around two thousand dollars
that's all it's thinking cars i got you
okay yeah i mean you got the money
you don't want to be below your
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses and you're getting pretty close
on that
because you only got 18 and you're
talking about spending 15 right
right yeah that was the thing yeah i
don't want to get below whatever three
months of your expenses are you don't
want to get below that in the account
after you buy that
well and we sell the chevy we get rid of
the nissan z
and then use some of the money out of
savings and get a new to him car
yeah that's what he's saying yeah but if
you may not get too much
you may not need the 15k out of pocket
because you got the proceeds from the
other two cars other two cars coming
yeah that might that may make up the
difference in the emergency fund because
the 3k
left in that emergency fund sounds
shallow yeah it does dave especially
living in jersey
i mean that's that's then so you know
let's just make sure you don't leave
yourself vulnerable because of a stupid
car
that's what it comes down to so it might
be a 12 000 car
you know that might be what you're after
i don't know but somewhere in there and
you're not over half your annual income
invested in things with wheels and
motors so you're cool there you're
paying cash so you're cool there
so overall the deal is good just don't
ever get below your three to six months
of expenses and emergencies
because you're inviting trouble that's
right it's like
sending out a ticket it is and even if
you've got to pick up gigs on the
weekend of fixing other people's cars
that's a natural side hustle for you you
love cars
you have the skill and talent to be able
to work on them so again thinking
outside the box
and you hold off two or three more
months and then maybe you can go get
that other
15 000. yeah yeah exactly right so
sacrifice
you got to make sure you have a plan for
that we live in a car
culture and i love cars i'm a car junkie
um so i kind of enjoy the whole process
of messing around with them and i enjoy
having a nice one and all that kind of
stuff not because i care what somebody
else thinks i just like driving them
yeah
and uh but the thing is they go down in
value so fast
and it is the largest thing that
everyone buys
that goes down in value it goes the
wrong way so you've just got to limit
the damage
that it does to your finances and that's
why we say no more than half your annual
income tied up in it
even if you're paying cash and you drive
really fast too
well there's that